hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast development of vascular access
port model in which sucks i'm robert
assalamu sub lab roots and i'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth
labyrinth is a leading scientific social
networking website to producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
contributing to the advancement of
science their content sharing
capabilities labyrinths is a powerful
advocating and supplying global networks
and communities we have a few important
announcements before words again this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we're going to
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge a scribe window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
click any technical problems hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation and oh I'll submit your
problems disagreeing truly one low and
left I'd like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Margaret our mother her
prefer being Pig Batchelder dr. Paige
bachelder has achieved her veterinary
degree in 1987 and a board certification
in laboratory animal medicine in 1997
her veterinary experience has included
private practice academic research
pharmaceutical research she has
contributed both of the laboratory
animal veterinarian and as a researcher
currently she works for bristol-myers as
a principal veterinary scientist the
rule includes serves on the animal care
youth committee as attending
veterinarian providing clinical care of
research animals collaborating
researchers developing surgical animal
models and overseeing the Animal Health
Insurance Program I'll now turn it over
to the doctor for her presentation hello
everyone and thank you for attending I'm
very happy to be presenting on my
favorite animal
Chuck and I don't know whether any of
you've had experiences woodchucks or if
you've had experience with vascular
access ports or vaps as i'm going to
call them but I'm hoping that experience
that we had putting that into woodchucks
will be give you something useful to
take home for the future or at least be
interesting and before I get into the
technical details of the the procedure I
would like to just give a quick
background on vascular access ports and
on woodchucks and why we might want to
put vascular access ports in woodchucks
so vascular access port is a way to
access the circulatory system by placing
a cannula in a vessel that runs to a
port which is under the skin so it's
completely implanted and can be pierced
with a needle percutaneously so it's
completely enclosed under the skin
nothing's hanging out to get infected
and they can last quite a long time in
people you know they can last for years
they were originally designed for people
who are getting frequent chemotherapy so
they didn't have to keep poking veins
and in research it's been used in
research animals when they need to have
a lot of blood samples or blood dosing
and you can put the port you know
wherever you want to put it in a
convenient site so sometimes that's
helpful as well it's considered a
refinement in animal research because if
there are a lot of blood samples taken
its overall less stressful for the
animal to have one surgery than it is to
have many many blood dress use of
vascular access ports has been reported
in many species you can see the list
here this is both clinical uses and
research uses if you are considering
placing vascular access port you do have
to weigh the risk of the anesthesia and
surgery competence surgery complications
versus the benefits
of the reduced handling and stress on
the animal after the port's been
implanted and again it's really a matter
of you know how much you should going to
get out of that port whether it weighs
in the balance of in favor of using the
port and which up a little background
woodchucks are native to the eastern and
northern parts of North America so the
United States and Canada primarily the
name comes from the Native American
woodchuck would chuck they're also
called groundhogs whistle pigs and land
beavers for though who those who are a
little challenged in identifying their
species and within the US and they are
mostly considered a pest because they
like to eat gardens they are quite large
they can weigh up to 15 pounds or six
kilograms that depends partly on their
weight and partly on their metabolic
state because they are a hibernating
species so they can lose quite a bit of
weight over the winter when they're
hibernating and then gained quite a bit
in the summer they have a stocky body
short legs and a tail and they're very
strong four limbs and long sharp claws
which they use to dig the burrows that
they live in woodchucks are the species
of which chuck is susceptible to
infection with woodchuck hepatitis virus
which is actually endemic in some
subpopulations which a Kappa tightest
virus is very similar both in structure
and in epidemiology and disease as human
hepatitis B virus and that is what makes
the woodchucks such a valuable model
hepatitis B virus can cause a number of
different diseases it could be
asymptomatic it can be an acute or
chronic hepatitis if it becomes in the
chronic state it can lead to cirrhosis
and eventually can lead to liver cancer
and so this is a really important
disease worldwide and the research
that's being done in wood
chuck's is helping to develop
therapeutics either to prevent the
infection or to try to alter the chronic
state so these immune system is enabled
to actually clear the virus to prevent
that chronic disease cirrhosis liver
failure and cancer this is the upper
picture is a human hepatocellular
carcinoma and the lower one is multiple
carcinomas from a woodchuck so what
Chuck's are an uncommon lab species
there are very few places that actually
will breed them for research use and as
I said they're considered a pest so
people don't usually keep them as pets
there is some information in the
literature but not a whole lot so when
we knew we were getting woodchucks in we
learned as much as we could and then got
them in and learned a whole lot more
just by experience woodchucks when
they're in their cages really appear
quite Gothel but they can be aggressive
especially if they're well caught
especially if you are trying to approach
them and they're scared and they can
cause serious bite and scratch wounds
with those big claws and they're big
rodent teeth because their bodies are
short and thick and their legs are short
tail is short they're hard to hold onto
the skin is very mobile so they can kind
of twist around inside inside their skin
because there's a very thick layer of
subcutaneous fat if you pick them up by
the tail they can actually climb up
their own tail and and they're very
strong if they get hold of something
while you're holding them they can pull
or push and therefore therefore legs are
very strong so in most cases if you want
to do anything with a woodchuck in the
lab you're going to have to anesthetize
it so as you can imagine if you are
doing multiple blood draws that's a lot
of anesthesia's and that's what our
studies involved we needed to dose
intravenously and we also had to take a
lot of blood samples so we felt that it
was worth the
of putting the animals through a longer
longer anesthesia the risks of surgery
in order to allow us to take blood
samples without having to anesthetize
them every time and it's also less
time-consuming if you don't have to
anesthetize them because it does take
them allowed to go down it also allows
we created a restrainer which allows
woodchuck to be strained with more
safety to the handlers and I'll show you
a picture that in a couple minutes and
when you are placing a bap they're
different vessels that you can place it
in place the cannula in we talked with
other people who had placed that babson
woodchucks and primarily they either
used the femoral vessels in the hind leg
or they used the what is commonly called
the jugular vein but actually it's the
anastomosis between the lingual facial
and maxillary veins under the jaw but
it's a lot easier to say jugular and we
looked at both methods we were most
experienced with doing femoral vessels
vaps in other species we had done dogs
and the techs and marmosets so that was
one of the reasons we decided to go with
the femoral a couple of other reasons
one is that that was closer to the back
end of the animal rather than the front
end of the animal where the teeth are so
that would allow us to put the port a
little farther away from danger and it
also was very easy to just grab the
woodchuck by the tail and kind of looked
at halfway up and you could see the
incision site during the post-operative
period it was very easy to check on that
as opposed to trying to look under the
animals neck and some of the animals we
implanted both arterial and venous in
the same leg other animals just had
arterial ports the animals that we had
we had quite a variety very eclectic
group
we had both sexes we had various ages
and these ages were often unknown they
were wild caught and some were infected
with which I kappa tightest virus and
some were not the infected ones for the
most part had a confirmed chronic
infection so they were not in the acute
stage and the wild caught ones were were
caught from an endemic wild populations
some were delivered directly to us from
trapping some were taken to the vendors
facility where he would condition them
worm them treat them kind of get them
through being used to captivity and then
sell them back to us for a large amount
of money he also would take any mothers
that were pregnant when they were
trapped and have them give birth in his
facility and he could infect the pups by
injecting the woodchuck hepatitis virus
and that gives a higher rate of
infection and just a natural infection
and of course everything we did was
approved by our Animal Care and Use
Committee the port that we actually used
was this access technologies clear port
we again it's something that we'd used
before their port heads were
pre-attached so we didn't have to you
know put them on the lines so this is
how we worked out preparing the animals
before surgery we gave them a pre
surgical anesthetic and so we had that
on board if a woodchuck was hepatitis
positive they would get a vitamin K
injection that's going to mention that
later as well that because they could
have hepatitis they might have decreased
ability to clot so we just wanted to
give them that little extra boost in
case their clotting factors worth a
little bit low and we fasted them
overnight although if they were
scheduled to have surgery in the
afternoon we would just ask them that
early that morning and the animals were
induced by either an inhalant and
aesthetic justice is on the other
picture or buy injectable anesthetic
agents
and we placed a cephalic IV catheter in
all the woodchucks and put them on
intra-operative fluids to help support
them an anesthetic maintenance was by
Isah flooring it was either given
through a face mask or we were able to
intubate some of the animals and I'll
talk about that more later if they were
on a face mask we had a vacuum system
that was near the head of the animal to
exhaust the leaked anesthetic gases so
the surgeons did not become anesthetized
we gave them a broad-spectrum antibiotic
and we also gave Dupin orphan SR which
is a long-acting long-acting analgesic
in other species it's supposed to last
up to three days so we felt that
hopefully in the species it would as
well and we kind of played around with
the dose started with rat doses and
diagnosis and kind of worked in between
if the dose was was a little too high it
made them go very deep in anesthesia so
it was interacting with the anesthetic
so we kind of twiddled around with the
dose and until we ended up with this
point five mix / keg and that worked
really well and we did check their blood
glucose before surgery and if they were
if it was low we would put a little
glucose into the fluids fluids were
warmed the body temperature was
maintained by heating plates underneath
the surgery drapes and they were was
also monitored throughout surgery as
well as body temperature we monitored
the respiratory rate heart rate the
oxygen saturation of the blood and if
the animals were intubated we could also
monitor in tidal co2 and the picture
here is one that's on a face mask but
some of the animals we were able to in
debate and then we could do that
monitoring as well
and a normal surgical prep of the
surgical site which is the inside of the
behind leg and obviously used sterile
technique throughout the surgery just
with any other species we would make an
incision find the vessels and use blunt
dissection to free up the vessels from
the surrounding tissues the head of the
vApp which is the support or head of the
baptist where the needles going to go in
and needed to be placed on the top of
the animal as opposed to underneath so
we would then flip the animal over and
make an incision over the wing at the
LEM and made a little subcutaneous
pocket could put supports in this is
this illustration here has to so this is
an arterial and venous and we would be
consistent about which was in fronting
which was behind so that we always knew
which one to hit depending on what we
wanted to do then you would use a trocar
to pass the cannulas down to the
incision area in in the England area so
that they would be able of thread into
the vessels at that point we would go
ahead and anchor the port head to the
muscle there's holes in the in the metal
head to put suture through and then we
would close up that incisions with the
animal back over and would be back in
England on area and to cannulate the
vessels we would tie off distally
temporarily clamp off with an a
traumatic vascular clamp or we could
just put some sutra around it and lift
it so that it cut off the blood supply
temporarily use very fine scissors to
make a little cut in the vessel wall and
then we're able to pass the cannula into
the vessel for most of us we like to use
magnifying loops to do this if you have
really good eyesight you can do it just
with your regular eye sight
and once the catheter or the cannulas in
place it's like ated into place and then
someone on the other side of the animal
will reach over to the port heads put
the needles in the port heads and flush
through the cannulas to make sure both
in and out that the blood will flow
freely in your if your ligatures are too
tight and you may have to loosen them up
a little because they can actually crush
the cannula so you kind of get a feel
for it after you've done a few our
incisions were closed in two layers with
a subcutaneous layer and a sub-q ler
vintage enclosure for the skin we used
absorbable suture and by using the foot
particular closure we did not have to
take any skin sutures out later which
you know was that much less handling for
the woodchuck and then we would flush
the but that's one last time make sure
they still worked and then lock them
with lock solution which we used pcs so
after surgery miss animals tended to
wake up quite quickly which is nice they
didn't stay sleep really long once
you've discontinued the anesthesia what
Chuck's are pretty easy to dose orally
so we did continue the antibiotics as
with oral solution we got a compounded
solution of enrofloxacin that was a high
concentration so the volume was pretty
small but the they are easy to to dose
with the feeding needle you just have to
get behind those big front teeth and
into their mouths and they will take it
quite readily based on experience with
other species and reports we did expect
the buprenorphine SR to provide at least
three days of alagaësia we didn't really
have any way to test it but I will say
we never saw any animals that look like
they were in pain so I think it worked
kind of hard to tell with the woodchuck
because they mostly just sit there
so we we had done you know what I've
described is pretty similar to what
we've done in other species but there
were some special considerations that we
learned along the way for this
particular species one is that
subcutaneous fat I mentioned before they
have a large layer of subcutaneous fat
and that so they can store lots and lots
of fat to go into hibernation so even
even in the winter time when they're at
a low metabolic state they still have
that fat layer and in many cases and you
could not reach the muscle layer to
suture your port heads down unless you
remove some of the fat so we actually
had to do lightech Tamizh or fat ekta
maze and so that you could get down to
where the muscle Chiefs were that would
hold these sutures on the port head
otherwise the port heads would have just
kind of floated around in that fat and
not been able to be pierced as easily in
other species we had placed the port
head up on the paraspinal area on the
back more towards the center of the back
and the width of the paraspinal area was
the correct size so the port head would
fit on it and in the case of the
woodchucks they did not have a very wide
paraspinal area and they also had a very
I won't I don't know if it's thin or
what you would say but the abdominal
wall is kind of floppy so there wasn't a
lot of support for the port head and if
you don't have support and you're trying
to put a needle in it's just going to
squish down into the into the body so we
located the port heads on a area over
the wing of the ilium so that the bones
the ilium bone would provide support for
the ports and we could push against that
bone when we were putting the needles is
so that was that was a little bit new
some other special considerations and
woodchuck apparently because they are a
hybrid natori species they have quite a
bit of variation
in body weight as I mentioned seasonally
and blood glucose body temperature
respiratory rate and very wide
variations and it did vary a little bit
with season as well because in the ops
in the winter season even though they
did not actually hibernate in the lab
they do go through a period of lowered
metabolism school so the Bandi weight
would vary with season the blood glucose
sometimes was quite lie hi or it could
be quite low as I mentioned we would
supplement if it was low but having a
blood glucose glucose over 200 was not
necessarily a problem body temperature
as well I could be lower than than you
would expect in an animal you would
expect them to be about 37 degrees
centigrade and they can drop quite low
to the point where in other species we
might be concerned but these guys
tolerated it very well and I think again
is because they do drop their body
temperature during hibernation the
respiratory rate could be very slow and
it was not unusual to have a respiratory
rate of four to six breaths per minute
so sometimes you're just sitting there
watching those watching them to take
that next breath and I mentioned that
they could be challenging the intubate
we intubated when we could and their
mouth opening is very small they have
flaps behind their front teeth that keep
the dirt out when they're tunneling and
the huge incisors kind of get in the way
of anything elongated narrow oral cavity
and we did try to use rabbit blades on
our laryngoscope and they were not
really long enough we even went so far
as to have a special blade designed and
made using a 3d printer and then we
found out that the focal point of the
laryngoscope light didn't align with the
back of the animal's mouth so it kind of
didn't light where we were it needed to
light so we just mostly intubated bye
bye feel and
by what we could see beyond the teeth
with their eyes we didn't try more than
two times to intubate an animal because
we found that if you kept pushing it
they would have a very they have a very
sensitive airway which would swell up
and could cause some obstruction so we
were very careful not to overdo it and
went to the mask if we weren't able to
get the tube in there was also a concern
about their lung capacity because they
have a huge abdomen full of guts that
they just all the food that they have to
eat their thorax was relatively small
and so we had to do things such as
tilting the table down so that the
weight of their gut contents wasn't
pressing on the diaphragm in some cases
they actually saw some abdominal
distension during surgery or during
induction of anesthesia we think it
might have been diet-related if they'd
had cabbage or something like that but
for some reason they would just start to
inflate and we immediately had to take
them off the anesthesia and reschedule
because that could put so much pressure
on the diaphragm that they would have
difficulty breathing only happened a
couple of times but it was quite
striking when it did I mentioned that
say infected animals could have
compromised liver function so that can
affect their glucose as well as their
clotting ability so we did pre treat
them with the vitamin K and once they
have gone through the surgery and and
are all healed and then you have to and
check the vApp on a regular basis if
it's being used obviously you're
checking it while you're using it if
it's in between studies we would check
them at least every two weeks and they
they were placed on the back end of the
animal and that was so that we could
access them easily when the animal was
awake by
using a custom-built restrainer so I'll
show you a picture here so the
restrainer is just basically a tube it's
about half the length of the animal so
the head with those big long teeth and
those big strong four limbs with the
claws on them are well contained within
the tube but the backend is out so that
we can access the ports it's hard to see
the ports in this photo but the
arrowheads are pointing to there are two
ports there as you can imagine just as a
side note because these animals do have
a lot of fat you'll often have to find
the port heads by feeling numb rather
than looking they kind of get buried and
for this setup we would put the animal
on the floor would be let out of its box
it's carried in a box we let them out on
the floor or in a big box on the floor
grab them by the tail flip them up
quickly on the table and then with the
gloved hand guide them into the tube and
then you use the glove hand to kind of
hold the hindquarters so they don't back
out they do feel more secure in the tube
they generally do not twist around and
try to escape once they're in there they
remain fairly calm and at the same time
your handlers both the which I candler
and the person taking samples are
protected from bites and scratches
everything that we did with the VATS was
done in a sterile fashion we would shave
if we had to and we found out that
woodchucks don't grow their hair back
all the time they tend to have one or
two seasons of the year where they grow
here and the rest of the time if you
shave it off it doesn't grow back so we
often did not have to shave the hair we
just had to do a surgical scrub of the
skin and then using sterile technique we
would pierce percutaneously into the
court head i'm using a Huber needle
huber needle is what they call an encore
a needle
this is the way that tip is angled it
will not cut a round hole in the
membrane of the port head and it just
kind of slips through without taking any
pieces out with it that way you can use
support had multiple times and this is a
picture of you know one person
restraining the woodchuck and the other
is withdrawing blood or flushing it's
going one way or the other with the
syringe you can see the sterile table
laid out there and it was fairly fairly
easy to do and the woodchucks did just
fine we had pretty good success with the
ports and we had all together we had
implanted 70 animals they all had in
arterial port and 48 of them had both
arterial and venous ports and they were
you know I've got statistics here they
were functional for most of them were
functional for at least 60 days which
was you know good enough to get them
through a study and many were still
functional after six months and keep in
mind that within that six months some of
those animals might have been euthanized
while the ports were still working at
the end of the study so the actual
percentage could even be higher than
that and then overall sixty percent of
the vets were still functional at the
time that the animal was was euthanized
or donated the longest duration that we
had was was one girl who had a bacterial
and lena steps both of them stayed
peyton up to seven hundred and three
days at which point she was donated so
who knows how long it would have gone so
i just want to give some acknowledgments
to some of the other people who were
very instrumental in this whole process
and that was the myers squibb heidi du
lac Gary marks he was our woodchuck
Wrangler and Kelly Welton was another
veterinarian
both she and Heidi could do the
surgeries as well as myself and Sharon a
born was another person who had been
trained to do the surgeries and she did
a lot of the anesthesia and james
Brennan was our alternative woodchuck
reg'lar at roswell park cancer institute
we went and visited them before we got
our would checks in and got a ton of
information from sandra sexton she was
very helpful and sharing the information
about their woodchuck colony and we did
definitely appreciate it so and I know I
kind of went through that quickly I
wanted to be sure we had plenty of time
for questions I can go back to any slide
you might want me to go back to or just
ask questions as you wish I see there's
a couple up their faces after for that
informative presentation and yes we'll
get started on that question and answer
session but before we do I would like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window might the doctor
said we're going to try to answer as
many questions as we can our first
question is what is a major disadvantage
of VAP is that claudine or contamination
I'm sorry could you repeat the question
please not a problem what is a major
disadvantage of EAPs is that claudine or
contamination in our hands the major
problem was clotting and we I'm thinking
if we ever even had one that got
infected we have had occasional
affections and other species but I don't
think any of our woodchucks ever did end
up with an infected port and so the main
reason that they would fail would be
from the clotting or kinking sometimes
the tubes would ya cannulas would get
kinked
our next question is oh I'm so sorry we
still no I was just going to mention in
passing that sometimes we would flush
the lines with agent remember what it
was and radio up a agent so that we
could see what the lines were doing and
we could see you know maybe they pulled
out of the vessel and the agent was just
going under the skin so there were ways
that we could kind of take a look at him
thank you in our next question is did
you see any injection site reaction with
a hbu Britain orphan SR we had some
problems using that in mice yes I've
heard about those problems in mice and
rats we did not see any problems at all
I don't know whether that's because of
woodchucks are immune to having that
kind of problem or just because you know
when you give a sub-q injection and the
woodchuck there's a huge space between
the skin and the body while for it to go
so you could have had a reaction under
the skin and we would never been aware
but we did not see anything and or feel
any bumps that were a problem our next
question is kind of leads into this what
kind of complications did you see with
surgery well there were a few and the
most distressing for us was an aesthetic
death and that happened a number of
times the first first time it happened
we were that we reviewed all of our
surgery procedures and that was when we
had decided to tip the table up and we
kind of changed the order that we did
things for the surgery to make it go a
little quicker and but we have to keep
in mind that some of these were
wild-caught animals and they could have
other problems woodchucks can get heart
disease and the ones that I necropsy did
in some cases appear to have enlarged
tarts and they could have other diseases
we had a woodchuck died not on the table
but it's inside of renal failure another
one had a big abscess in
abdomen that we didn't even know was
there until it ruptured and so they can
be carrying other complicating factors
that you're not aware of and but they
can go quite quickly and you can be
watching for that one breath every 15
seconds and then it's late and then next
thing you know the animal was gone so
that was kind of the most distressing
complication and the hardest one to try
to avoid and you know we did everything
we possibly could think of to not have
that happen we did not have a major any
major problems with infection and the
incisions even though they're underneath
the animal and down in the bedding and
seem to stay pretty clean the animals
would leave them alone we did have one
animal that had developed a hematoma but
that resolved just with conservative
treatment so not a whole lot of
complications well thank you so you
mentioned here that some of your animals
that you caught on were wild [ __ ] did
you have any issues with pre-existing
health conditions and were you concerned
about rabies yeah and well I just
mentioned a couple of pre-existing
health conditions the kidney failure had
come on I mean we were monitoring their
blood work all along so her video ID and
creatinine started going up just like in
any other animal we kept an eye on her
and and she did have spontaneous kidney
failure and we had the one with the
abscess that that turned up as a sudden
death unexpected but when we opened her
up there was what i would have sworn was
a hemangioma it was huge full of pockets
of blood and one of those pockets had
disrupted so at some point in her life
in the wild she had gotten a kidney
infection and many of them came in with
wounds or scars from wounds and one had
an injury to the eye and had entropion
so we did surgery on the eyelid to try
to reduce that entropion effect on the
eye and you know they could have missing
teeth or claws
some of them came in with a photo
dermatitis sores on the bottoms of the
feet which are very difficult to treat
usually if that happened after we
received them we would catch it quickly
and they would be curable but the ones
that came in with it it was generally
already chronic and difficult to treat
those are probably the main things well
thank you before we met book today teens
any closing remarks for us and well I
just want to say I really love the
species it was very interesting and
exciting to have them in the lab I'm
sorry we don't have them anymore and as
I mentioned before there's not a whole
lot of information out there but it's
really good to get to know people who've
had them or have them and talk with them
and get information firsthand again I
went to rest World Cancer Institute and
Sandra was very helpful and I would be
helpful glad to be helpful to anybody
who gets woodchucks in the future will
again doctor thank you very much for
your time in that outstanding
presentation that also like to thank
lavaridge to making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May 2017 you'll receive an email from
labret alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to for that announcements to your
colleagues who may miss today's blog
events and goodbye